[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro 17 8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mardi 28 mai
c'était une famille de passionnés des
collectionneurs les lambinet se dévoile
dans la nouvelle exposition du musée qui
porte leur goût à versailles le marathon
musical de maître assassin revient la
tour mais les ouates 10 heures de
concert et dix artistes à l'espace
decaux villes de voisins-le-bretonneux
pour sa huitième édition le festival
courants d'art des longs cours proposé
une balade en forêt les écoles de danse
et d'arts plastiques se réunissaient
pour présenter le fruit de leur travail
à la ferme du mousseau lambiner avant
d'être un musée c'est une famille d
artistes des collectionneurs des
passionnés le site versailles et a
choisi de leur rendre hommage à
l'occasion du 90e anniversaire de
donation de l'hôtel à la ville nathalie
lambiner la dernière propriétaire de
l'hôtel
celle qui sait de la maison familiale à
la ville de versailles à sa mort en 1926
à la condition d'en faire un musée
elle avait souhaité garder un souvenir
dans ce lieu important pour elle ces
lieux doit elle était heureuse avec son
fils mort prématurément et elle explique
dans son testament qu'elle souhaite
faire donc dieu l'hôtel lambiner en
guise et pour la ville de versailles et
elle va jusqu'à indiquer les horaires
d'ouverture les jours de fermeture
qu'elle a recruté un conservateur
les lambinet des descendants de tailleur
de marchands de vêtements passionné
d'art leur collection est estimée entre
300 et 500 pièces un goût typique de la
belle époque dont une grande partie des
oeuvres a été dispersée
de cette famille passionnée une salle
est accordée à aimer lambiner l'artiste
soutenu par son oncle maire de
versailles
il devient le disciple de jean baptiste
camille corot il est devenu peintre de
paysages historique
un genre qui a été créée en 1817 et
progressivement il va en fait commencé à
travailler en plein air puisque cours au
conseil c'est différent disciples emule
de faire confiance en fait alors
impression première de rester sensible à
la nature sans oublier toujours de
retourner travailler en atelier devenu
musée en 1932 l'hôtel rassemble
aujourd'hui des pièces des collections
les lambiner et de la bibliothèque
municipale de la commune pour devenir le
musée d'art de la cité royale
[Musique]
160 pages illustrées pour découvrir le
patrimoine de mantes-la-jolie la ville
se dévoile dans un ouvrage proposé par
le service patrimoine et inventaires de
la région ile-de-france un passé en
éternel devenir c'est son titre emmène à
la découverte de la collégiale des
fortifications de l'hôtel-dieu et bien
d'autres lieux qui font la commune des
précisions de julie corteville chef du
service elle était l'invitée de grégory
qu'à l'aller ils déroulent depuis gaza
depuis la chapelle de gaza cours au 12e
jusqu'au val fourré aujourd'hui toutes
les étapes et on laborde vraiment en
termes de patrimoine parce que on essaye
de comprendre comment comment évolue ce
territoire et quel est l'état du
patrimoine du plus ancien au plus
contemporain
aujourd'hui et pour voir l'intégralité
de cet entretien direction notre site
internet
un nouveau marathon pour les passionnés
de musique et de concert le 8 juin
prochain la tour mais les watts revient
dix heures de live 10 artistes et on
fait le point sur ce rendez-vous avec
l'un des organisateurs pierre michel
plongeon bonjour bonjour est le
coordinateur de metas qui organise cette
soirée et cette année donc c'est la
troisième édition avec toujours cette
idée de mêler les groupes émergents les
groupes locaux et les têtes des fiches
ce ça nous qu'on recommence pour une
troisième édition avec grand plaisir et
vous l'avez très bien expliqué notre but
c'est voile pouvoir proposer des têtes
d'affiché françaises ou internationales
la scène indépendante est également de
favoriser voilà la diffusion des groupes
émergents à du territoire quand on pense
à 10 heures de concert on va vers des
groupes différents il ya un fil rouge
commence à se construire une telle
soirée
alors ça là on est encore sur un petit
fil rouge de cette année même style que
l'édition précédente
donc on va retrouver de la musique rayé
de
hip hop électro alors la nouveauté cette
année c'est le petit fil conducteur
c'est l'esprit punk
donc on va accueillir un groupe comme
les ramoneurs de menhirs voilà c'est du
peuple breton très festif surprenant
voilà et gérard baste aussi voilà des
linkers donc un groupe de hip hop mais
avec une culture un peu punk et
bizarrement niveau ce serait bizarre
pourquoi du reggae du punk et ben en
fait historiquement ces deux mouvements
se sont rencontrés et donc on a voulu
proposer voilà ce festival cette édition
là avec cette couleur là en tout cas et
on trouve les groupes comment on épluche
dans ses contacts aussi parce que meta
sauce rencontre beaucoup d'artistes on
va dans d'autres concerts alors cette
année ça que sur les dix groupes qu'on a
programmé il ya une partie qu'on a pu
découvrir voilà on est allons voir des
festivals par exemple sur le territoire
constamment un canton pour rien on va
tous mêlés ou qui on est partenaires ont
fait comme ça aussi chaque année des
découvertes et puis le réseau
professionnel qu'on a pu tisser depuis
des années là on a travaillé notamment
avec l'ancien directeur et programmateur
qui était d'ailleurs le fondateur de
l'association qui nous a filé un coup de
main pour cette addition en faisant
jouer son contact son réseau et c'est
comme ça qu'on ait pu avoir si ces
milliers à cette année sinsemilia fait
l'une des têtes d'affiché voir la tête
d'affiche et qu'ils n'agissent que les
jours opposent qu'on les écoute
[Musique]
la solution
j'ai mal au monopole de l'intelligence
mais j'attends les mots s'envolent de sa
caste au silence par le parlement
sinsemilia toujours reconnaissable à la
première écoute
pour ce morceau ils sont avec guizmo de
tryo et bellick de danakil et reviennent
après un an d'absence
c'est ça ils sont sorties d'albums cette
année ça faisait un petit moment qu'on
les avait pas vus donc c'était vraiment
l'occasion un peu une exclusivité pour
nous de les avoir et de les faire venir
à 50 ans de glynn donc on est très
content et on s'est effectivement oui
plutôt facilement plutôt facilement il
était disponible
et puis on les a eus en fait si on les
programme en avait que volodia
qui est elle même tourneur qui les fait
tourner ensemble donc pour la découverte
comme ça nous allait très bien donc on a
hâte que le public voit la saint
quentinois des yvelines et même
d'ailleurs puissent venir à l'événement
à découvrir voilà ce groupe mythique au
festival et volodia voulons nous en
avait parlé c'est l'inde autre un des
autres dix artistes on va l'écouter
[Musique]
il faut que je m'en aille
pour le détail
[Musique]
je
jour estival
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évoquée
[Musique]
on veut aller
là on est plus dans le reggae mêlée au
hip hop totalement encore un mélange
c'est ça là on vraiment sûr quelque
chose plus actuelle un peu plus moderne
ce qui se fait actuellement en tout cas
dans ce style de musique là et ben c'est
quelque chose d'assez frais puis sur
scène c'est pas toujours festif ça donne
le moral le sourire on arrive sur les
bijoux enfin on espère quand même
scola le mois de mai quand même pas
terrible compliqué mais lui juin sur un
super temps comme chaque année super
soleil donc c'est la musique idéale
voilà pour commencer un peu à faire la
fête pardon sortir et profiter du beau
territoire qu'on a
alors là on a cité quelques groupes vous
avez dit aussi les ramoneurs de menhirs
mais aussi dogmatique suns se saignent
visor et y en a même qui viennent de
l'étranger
ça vient du canada si je mets trop
dogmatique c'est un dj dup du canada qui
est canadien par donc on est très
content de pouvoir l'accueillir aussi en
effet pour trouver bien sûr la
programmation sur les réseaux sociaux
les sites internet
c'est super donc voilà dix groupes
on est très contents aussi va pouvoir
faire jouer pour citer quelques noms
what the fuck cependant toujours ses
esprits natural trance ou on a également
moko qu'il ya un projet assez
particulier donne pas mal d'influx ans
qu'on voit bien le pâté on me dira pour
utiliser une expression sympathique
donc voilà ne ratez pas ces groupes là
j'ai envie de vraiment vos spectateurs à
venir découvrir la richesse qu'on a
musical en tout cas des groupes
j'espère qu'il vous entends ces dix
heures de musique en plus non stop
il ya deux semaines pour se remettre le
lien alors on a beaucoup parlé musique
live pour le moment mais il ya un autre
esprit dans votre festival un esprit
écolo un esprit environnementale vous
favoriser les circuits courts c'est un
moment de sensibilisation aussi oui ça
c'est très important ce nom laden
du festival et de l'association de
toujours promouvoir ce qu'on peut faire
au quotidien as que c'est un sujet
d'autant plus d'actualité on en parle de
plus en plus enfin j'ai envie de dire
enfin que cette question là sont prise
au sérieuse et consent cette nécessité
là alors nous bien sûr on a mis en place
un certain nombre de choses on a le tri
sélectif on a utilisé des gobelets
réutilisables
on voit maintenant partout dans les
festivals ou dans des salles de concerts
qui viennent collector pour certains
acteurs on a les fameuses toilettes
sèches qu'elles sont très connus dans
notre festival voilà une animation qui
pâtit vic
voilà exactement après les nouveautés de
cette année par exemple c'était sur nos
outils de communication les a fait du
papier recyclé les t-shirts qu'on fait
pour les bénévoles on utilise deux voilà
une société qui utilise des encres sans
produits chimiques le moins possible de
l'anc raoult et voilà c'est plein de
petites choses mais au bout tabou qui
permettent de passer un message vous
favorisez aussi le covoiturage sur votre
site on peut se rencontrer vous cherchez
à faire se déplacer les gens vélo il y
en a un teint ou en vélo
voilà c'est plein de petites choses
qu'on peut le public pourra découvrir le
8 juin merci jamais vers ce plateau or
n'a bien sûr pas pu présenter tous les
artistes présentés toute cette soirée
qui commence à 16 heures qui stagne à 2
heures du matin mais pour ceux qui
voudraient en savoir plus bien sûr la
programmation direction le site internet
du festival
je le rappelle la tour mais les watts et
le samedi 8 juin faire se rencontrer les
élèves et les professeurs de deux écoles
tous les deux ans et l'encours propose
courants d'art son festival autour des
arts plastiques et de la danse
il se tenait samedi à la ferme du
mousseau invitant cette année le public
à une balade dans la forêt les images
sont signés patrick jacques de dixmude
ont fait des araignées d'aidé
et c'est avec de l'argile les petites
bêtes ont envahi la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt ont fêté la nature et la forêt
le thème du 8e festival courants d'art
l'idée c'est avec les enfants de
réaliser tous ces animaux en argile ou
avec des éléments qu ont accueilli ce
matin avec les enfants pour voilà créer
ces petites bêtes on s'est rendu compte
que c'était vraiment un sujet
d'actualité qu'en termes scientifiques
il y avait beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes mais aussi en termes
poétiques
la forêt c'est un c'est un lieu de
l'imaginaire c'est c'est le lieu du
grand méchant loup de l'ogre de la belle
au bois dormant et c'est un lieu
voilà qui parle à toutes les générations
des ateliers de création des expositions
et des performances
le festival est organisé tous les deux
ans par les écoles de la ville
elle prépare et créé en commun l'idée
c'est vraiment le travail
transdisciplinaire c'est à dire faire se
rencontrer les disciplines et faire
pratiquer ensemble des gens issus de
disciplines différentes c'est proposer
aux danseurs de pratiquer les arts
plastiques s'est proposé aux plasticiens
de découvrir la danse
pour cette huitième édition une
plasticienne un chorégraphe et les
itinéraires poétiques ont été associés
quatre ouvrages lu et étudié en cours
pour un prix la semaine dernière 350
élèves de 50 ans navy remettait le prix
des collégiens lecteurs de poésie
d'aujourd'hui
ce prix est organisé depuis trois ans
sur le territoire et c'est une auteure
locale qui a été désigné regardez des
textes pensée est couché sur le papier
en 2015 lydia pas de lait qu'a voulu
transmettre ses pensées ses émotions sur
les événements tragiques parisien j'ai
pas écrit ce recueil pour un public
spécifique mais c'est vrai que je
pensais c'était un petit peu difficile
pour
public collégiens et ils ont choisi
sansan de connaître en fait donc ça que
ça encore vraiment plus plus important
puisque justement ils ne me connaissent
pas et c'est vraiment le texte qu'ils
ont choisie pour ce prix les ya pas de
lait qui était face à trois autres
ouvrages avec un jury inédit 350
collégiens saint quentinois
tout d'abord on a été dit que la
couverture et on a classé en fond
d'affaires classement provisoire des
livres qu'on avait le plus à celui qu'on
a nommé le mois et après on à entrer
dans le vif du sujet on va regarder
vraiment ce qu'ils avaient dans le livre
c'était sympa de faire appel à des
collégiens pour fort à la poésie parce
que souvent emballer les jeunes et baena
puisse pas vendre la poésie et faire
appel à des jeunes va c'est quand même
assez original on en apprend beaucoup
des du poète 1
franchement c'est génial oui moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé comme ça j'ai découvert la
poète et beaucoup de livres le prix
collégiens lecteurs de poésie
d'aujourd'hui existe depuis trois ans
piloté par les itinéraires poétique
qu'il vise à diffuser la poésie
contemporaine des ouvrages ont tous été
édité récemment fait un choix dans tout
ce qu'on reçoit ce ne sont pas des
livres destinés à la jeunesse c'est ça
c'est voulu et enfin choix qui permet de
montrer une l'éclectisme delà de la
création poétique mais aussi les
critiques de l'édition poétique à
travers des ouvrages de forme va dire de
toucher différents aussi un travail
réalisé en cours ou lors d'ateliers les
collégiens ont aussi réalisé des vidéos
autour des textes étudiés 14 classes ont
participé à cette troisième édition et
après les collégiens les lycéens ont
rejoint en plateau catherine boucher et
moufida vivier respectivement professeur
de lettres au lycée de ville envoie à
guyancourt et bibliothécaires du réseau
des médiathèques monge aura toutes les
deux alors cette année vous avons cadré
des élèves avec lectures pour tous mon
petit avis en quelques mots une
présentation du parcours
le parcours lecture pour tous donc en
fait c'est un parcours les terrains en
bibliothèque
l'objectif principal c'est d'inciter et
de donner l'habitude aux lycéens de
fréquenter les lieux culturels qui sont
les bibliothèques dont sur le territoire
et le but si je dis que s'il ya c'est un
but c'est vraiment de leur donner envie
de leur donner d'autres entrées à la
lecture que la à prendre le livre et se
met à lire comme la lecture silencieuse
ou lecture à voix haute les médiathèques
de 50 ans l'une ont donc travaillé trois
classes de l'agglomération pour vous des
gens professionnels c'est un autre
travail vers le public d'aller dans une
classe d'aller vers des classes non
c'est vraiment pour une bibliothécaire
du réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin c'est la seml c'est le même
travail mais travailler autrement c'est
vrai ça fait partie
c'est vraiment de d'aller dans les
cartables dans les classes la médiation
du livre là le le côté artistique et
culturel médiathèque c'est notre métier
c'est notre quotidien
catherine bouchard professeur de lettres
pourquoi vous participez à ce parcours
alors je participe à ce parcours tout
simplement pour aider mes élèves à lire
parce que tous les moyens sont bons pour
essayer d'obtenir une lecture une
lecture silencieuse une lecture à voix
haute et surtout c'était l'occasion en
abordant le thème du corps d'incarner la
lecture mon but c'était vraiment de leur
donner l'occasion de rentrer dans la
lecture par une incarnation de cette
lecture puisque seulement c'est un peu
rébarbatif on a tous souvenir de nos
corps de lettres au lycée surtout quand
on arrive au bac vous faut les lire
parce qu'on va être interrogé dessus
c'est aussi peut-être pour les rassurer
leur faire comprendre qu'ils peuvent
lire oui alors la lecture est utilisée
même instrumentalisée dans l'éducation
nationale puisqu'elle sert à la fois
alice s'approprier une culture et à être
évalués à être sélectionné et
nos élèves de jeunes qui sont très
conscients ils sont très intelligents
comprennent très bien l'enjeu est donc
il leur est difficile quand ils refusent
cette système d'évaluation et de
dépression il leur est difficile de ne
pas refuser en même temps la lecture
donc le but était de désolidariser en
quelque sorte
l'analyse l'écriture le travail
rébarbatif de la vielle habitude de la
lecture elle même de l'appréciation de
la situation des personnages la rendre
ludique la ronde la rendre plus vivante
et en même temps pour que ça marche il
fallait aussi l'associer au programme du
baccalauréat donc il fallait jongler
avec les deux mon but c'était de
d'associer leur donner envie de lire
d'un côté et leur permettent d'utiliser
cette lecture de lettres dans leurs
épreuves notamment le midi et un thème
cette année c'est le corps y en avait
deux au fait au départ la lumière ou le
corps pourquoi avoir choisi le corps
nous fidèles de g pourquoi on a choisi
le corps quand on avait commencé à
construire ensemble
on avait peut-être parce qu'on avait
pensé à certains titres déjà pourquoi
pour composer le corpus
on avait déjà commencé à parler de
certains titres et en fait ces titres là
c'est plus le corps qui est traité comme
thème et c'est pourquoi on s'est dit
pourquoi pas encore on aurait pu choisir
et lumière néant nous aurait posé la
question pourquoi la lumière oui c'est
les ouvrages qui vous ont donné envie
alors on va en découdre et ça on va en
découvrir certains à l'antenne il ya de
tout il ya des classique antigone boule
de suif qu'on a tous lu pendant nos
études et des ouvrages moins connus
comme coors est bien de robert desnos
j'espère que je prône odin le nom de
famille ce sont des choix qui ont
surpris vos élèves d'un boucher ah oui
desnos les a surpris oui dans quel sens
alors c'est un écrivain surréaliste et
donc l'aspect illogique des associations
d'idées qui préside à l'écriture les a
déstabilisés
d'une part et d'autre part grand nombre
de ses textes une dimension érotique
donc c'est aussi pour des jeunes gens
c'était un petit peu difficile à
affronter
alors la structure du recueil fait que
ans l'étudiant arrive assez rapidement
avoir le la beauté des sentiments de
lyrisme
donc ça s'est bien passé mais ils ont
été déstabilisés
ils n'ont été aussi en partie par le
sujet de flammes
donc c'était le premier la première
avait choisi avec le vivier et le but
était qu'il la voit au théâtre et qu'ils
puissent eux mêmes jouets ce que flamme
c'est ahmed madani l'a présenté sur les
156 noël voilà peu dans un avait vu il
ya deux ans deux ans j'avais amené mes
élèves dans le cadre d'un pacte impact
vraiment théâtre est vraiment j'avais vu
que cette pièce leur parler et donc
j'avais sachant qu'elles étaient
publiées j'avais envie de l'étudier et
de la de l'utiliser comme tremplin pour
incarner la lecture et ça fonctionnait
ils ont été surpris lundi dans un sens
qui les a attirés
ils ont été nombreux à avoir envie de
baisser les leurs coups de coeur leurs
livres préférés avec eux des travaux
avec en moyenne à seulement bas on peut
pas tout citer
mais je voudrais juste qu'on passe à
dépasser la simple lecture moufida xvi a
aussi eu des ateliers alors aux
activités diverses il est des rencontres
avec une journaliste culturel notamment
en fait ce parcours
si je continue à définir ce que c'est
que ce parcours donc les élèves ou la
classe un script dans profitent de cinq
ateliers
donc on avait aussi construit les
ateliers ensemble
c'était sorti au tertre avec la lecture
de texte de la pièce
rencontre avec une journaliste et
critique littéraire martin laval pour
découvrir le métier et faire un atelier
avec l écrire produire quelque chose
rencontre avec une hauteur d'un roman
contemporain rage donc et aussi l'autre
oui c'est de l'écriture aussi de la
production en fait ces ateliers été fait
de façon que les ans les élèves soient
actifs intéressé au départ on passe
après à la création c'est ils ont crié
ils ont crié des sanguines que la
littérature peuvent aussi ils peuvent
aussi offerts ils ont créé une aussi
longue lecture des textes c'était là la
partie création et ils sont devenus
autonomes aussi à au final c'est eux
mêmes qui avaient choisi des extraits de
leurs deux pièces de théâtre pour les
jouets pour les présenter au final
c'était ça qui est passé à la
restitution qui a eu lieu le 14 mai à la
bnf la bibliothèque face aux mavs
narcisse et je voudrais juste qu'on
termine sur la réaction de vos élèves
catherine bouchard
est-ce qu'ils ont été plus attentif -
forcément plus forcément plus c'est une
attention d'une autre nature
c'est à dire qu'on ne fait pas attention
de la même manière un cours comprend
notre dont on sait qu'il va falloir le
mémoriser le restituer manière et on ne
fait pas attention de la même manière
quand on on rentre dans un lien affectif
avec une oeuvre ou avec une personne
comme ça leur est arrivé avec ahmed
madani ou avec par exemple rien de
charpentier qui a écrit rage donc merci
à toutes les deux on a un peu pris par
le temps
pour rappel vous nous parliez de la
participation à lecture parc pour tous
pardon c'est un parcours scolaire en
lien qui les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et on passe
maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
trois ans de découverte d'apprentissage
mercredi 29 mai les jeunes membres de
l'orchestré demos sur la scène de
l'opéra royal du château de versailles
les 93 jeunes du département montreront
ainsi au public le fruit de leur travail
ce samedi c'est la 8ème édition du
festival du court métrage des
clayes-sous-bois amateurs et passionnés
vous êtes attendus dès 14 heures à
l'espace fille noire et pour découvrir
les 13 films en compétition des duels
épiques de cape et d'épée jeudi 30 mai
les mousquetaires investissent le
château de breteuil les lames sur seine
feront une démonstration d'escrimé
artistique le 1er juin prochain débute à
versailles la 24e édition du mois
molière et c'est à cette occasion le
journaliste et écrivain franck ferrand
s'installe au théâtre montansier le
dimanche 12 juin pour 5 enregistrements
le rendez vous est donné à 18h et
véronique ithurbide y consacrera un
vip3a sera diffusée prochainement sur
notre antenne toujours au théâtre
montansier un spectacle pour les enfants
à partir de 4 ans avec l'enfant de l'
orchestre morgan parra ou raconte
l'histoire de hama une petite fille née
dans un grand orchestre symphonique un
moyen de découvrir les grands titres de
la musique classique et du théâtre
direction la ville des essarts le roi la
troupe la divine comédie interprète une
semaine pas plus
le synopsis paul même plus aux filles
mais n'ose pas lui avouer il invite
alors son meilleur ami dans le but de
faire exploser son couple à votre ville
à voir le samedi 1er juin et c'est la
fin de cette étude culture merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]